welcome back in the last video I told
you that that pressure times volume is a
constant that if you increase the
pressure or if you increase the volume
you're going to decrease the pressure
and hopefully you got an intuitive sense
why or or likewise if you squeezed the
balloon or the box and there are no
openings there then the pressure within
the box would increase so with that said
let's see if we can do a couple of
fairly typical problems that you'll see
so let's say that I don't know I have a
box or a balloon or something and let's
say it has a volume so let me call this
the initial volume let me let me erase
all of this so let's say my initial
volume is 50 cubic meters and let's say
my initial pressure my initial pressure
is 500 Pascal's just so you remember
what's a Pascal that's 500 Newton's per
meter 500 Newton's per meter cubed and
then what is and then let's say that I
take that box or balloon or whatever and
I compress it down to 20 meters cubed so
let's say I compress it so I squeeze it
so that was like the first example I
gave last time but it's the same
container and I squeezed it down to 20
meters cube what's going to be the new
pressure well you should immediately
have an intuition that what happens when
you squeeze the balloon it becomes
harder to do it sorry I just had some
peanuts I should have had some water
with it um my throat's very dry but
anyway I'll try to soldier through this
this this video so what's going to be
the new pressure well it's definitely
going to be higher right when you
decrease the volume the pressure
increases they're inversely related so
the pressure is going to go up and let's
see if we can calculate it well we know
that p1 times v1 is equal to some
constant and and since we have no
aggregate change in energy right I'm
just telling you that the box is
squeezed I'm not telling you whether it
did any work or anything like that
that the same constant is going to be
equal to the new pressure times the new
volume is going to be equal to p2 times
v2 so you could just have the general
relationship p1 times v1 is equal to p2
times v2 assuming that no work was done
and there was no exchange of energy from
outside of the system and in most of
these cases when you see this an exam
that is the case so the old pressure was
500 Pascal's times 50 meters cubed and
one thing to keep in mind because we're
using both the same units on the same
side because this is an equivalent this
equivalence is not equal we're not
saying it has to equal to some necessary
absolute number for example we don't
know exactly what this K is although we
could figure it out right now as long as
you're using one unit for pressure on
this side and one unit for volume on
this side you just have to use the same
units so we could have done this same
exact problem the exact same way if
instead of meters cubed
they said liters and as long as we
wanted we had liters here you just have
to make sure using the same units on
both sides so in this case we have 5500
Pascal's of pressure the volume is 50
meters cubed that's going to be equal
excuse me to the new pressure p2 times
the new volume 20 meters cubed and so
let's see what we can do we can divide
both sides by 10 so we can name you know
just take a 10 out of there and then we
could divide both sides by 2 so that
becomes a 250 and so we we get 250 times
5 is equal to p2 and so p2 is equal to
1200 and 50 Pascal's and if we kept with
the unit's you would have seen that so
when I decreased the volume by more you
know by roughly 60% is how much I
decrease the volume I have the pressure
actually increased by two and a half so
that that gels with what we talked about
before now let's let's add another
variable into this
mix let's talk about temperature and and
like pressure and like volume and like a
work and a lot of concepts that we talk
about in physics temperature is
something that you probably are at least
reasonably familiar with right
temperature
I mean you how do you view temperature
temperature I think if a high
temperature means something is hot and a
low temperature means something is cold
and I think you that also gives you
intuition that that a higher temperature
object has more energy right higher
temperature has higher energy right the
Sun has more energy than a then an ice
cube right I think that's fair enough
and I think you also have the sense that
what what would have more energy a a
hundred degree a hundred degree let me
think of something a cup of tea a cup of
tea or or a hundred degree let me do I
don't know
that of that of a you know barrel of tea
I want to make them equivalent in terms
of what they're holding so I think I
think you have the sense even though
they're the same temperature they're
both pretty warm let's say this one
hundred degrees Celsius so they're both
boiling that the barrel because there's
more of it it's going to have more
energy right it's it's equally hot and
it's just there's just more molecules
there and so that's what temperature is
temperature temperature in general is a
measure roughly is is equal to some
constant times the kinetic energy the
average kinetic energy kinetic energy
per molecule for molecule sorry it's the
average kinetic energy for molecule so
the average kinetic energy of the system
divided by the total number of molecules
we have so if I took so it's it you I
guess another way we could talk about it
is temperature is essentially energy for
molecule so something that has a lot of
molecules where n is the number of
molecules right so another way we could
view this is that the kinetic energy of
the system of the system is going to be
equal to the number of molecules times
the temperature and you know this is
just a constants of you know times 1
over K but 1 over K we don't even know
what this is so we could say that's
still a constant so the kinetic energy
of the system is going to be equal to
some constant times the number of
particles times temperature right and we
don't know what this is and we're going
to figure this out later so this is
another interesting concept we said that
pressure times volume is is proportional
to the kinetic energy of the system of
the system the aggregate if you take all
of the molecules and combine their
kinetic energies and these are the same
case I mean I could put another constant
here I call that k1 and we also know we
also know that that the kinetic energy
of the system is equal to some other
constant I don't know times the number
of the number of the number of molecules
I have times the temperature right so if
you think about it you could also say
that you know this is proportional to
this and this is proportional to this so
you could say that pressure times volume
is proportional to the number and these
are all different proportional constants
we'll figure out this exact constant
later but we can say the pressure times
volume is proportional to the number of
molecules we have times temperature and
recent kind of temperatures is we can
kind of view it as energy per molecule
or another way we could say that if this
constant is constant which it is by
definition let me change colors and the
number of molecules is constant we have
PV over temperature pressure times
volume over temperature is going to be
equal to something times the number of
molecules so we could say that's some
other constant I don't know k4 so this
is another interesting thing to think
about we said pressure times volume is
equal to pressure times volume now we
added temperature into the mix
so let's let me clear this up I think I
got my throat back so we could say p1
times v1 times over t1 is equal to p2
times v2 over t2 and does this make
sense to you let's say what happens if
if I have another box and you know I
have my particles bouncing around like
always and they're you know I have some
volume and some some amount of pressure
what happens when the temperature goes
up what am I saying
well I'm saying that the average kinetic
energy per molecule is essentially going
to go up so they're going to bounce
against the walls more so if they bounce
against the walls more the pressure is
going to go up right
assuming volume stays flat right another
way you could you could think about it
let's say let's say the temperature goes
up and I increase and let's say the
pressure stays flat so what did I have
to do well I just said if the
temperature goes up the average kinetic
energy of each molecule they'll bounce
more so in order to make them bounce the
against the sides of the walls as often
I'd have to increase the volume so if
you hold pressure constant the only way
you can do that is by increasing the
volume while you increase the
temperature so let's keep this in mind
and we will use this to solve some
pretty typical problems in the next
video